let me tell you if you think because
we're Christians and I'm holding this
cross that you could come here you can
lie in our faces and then you can attack
our people
register
they said he's not an Islamic slowly
dunnock squad come and we had a Quranic
scholar scholar discuss we got a lot of
friends with Kurds yeah not recorded
though what's it about much just
basically generally for example I just
heard you talk and as a Muslim I'm
British myself and you talked about
their was Muslim gangs we know that we
know that's been on the news and
personally myself as a British Muslim
everything you said there but everything
I'll say about 20-25 set of stuff I
agree with because the thing is my
question here is to you Rick SOI give me
one sec in the corner as well cuz
everyone knows well I just
I just came here to shake your hand does
that have anything to do with your
prophet saying that women are deficient
in intelligence no or deficient in
religion not really because there's a
god it's not seated unclean hello of
muslin up the first University was built
by a Muslim woman education is key for
Muslim woman I came here today to say
about what you said most some of the
stuff I agree how why I wanted to say is
look as a Muslim I'm British I'm Kurdish
yeah okay now you talked about cumin
guns yeah for example I don't move in
grooming guns I don't give a damn if
they're Muslim non-muslim if if you guys
said we're gonna go after all grooming
guns you decide if they're Muslim or
non-muslim I'll be right behind you guys
if you want to go off the terrorists I
will go off the Musa Isis and they want
to be yes put them as me in this country
you're not even a permanent or you want
to join it to please I've seen white
Hogan I've seen one and lived in terror
attack okay which was reactive it was
that silly bugger that drove into those
people of the most innocent graceful
right there's one one act a reaction
okay to children being scraped off the
wall of Manchester Arena right not
making it right it's disgusting
okay you point out to me where our seek
grooming games where are the Hindu
grooming gangs
where are the 18 screaming games where
are they the epidemic comes from the
scriptures okay from your prophet look
which says that the kuffar Allah said
that the core file can be taken the core
file women in children to be taking a
sex slave that is true that's true
and we going to get it to K I don't in
the book no what does it say you do
takea you here is a principle what I'm
saying is the book and the happy yeah
play expressly states that the Muslims
are permitted
it's a non-reciprocal for women children
or fix nasal as an act of jihad
I heard you understand your highness
that there is what if you guys can show
Nia you see terrorist attacks yes Allah
hasn't been Muslims my my issue is this
can you show me a single verse in the
Quran the hadith and the Islamic
literature where it says go and kill
innocent
I will cast terror into the hearts of
the disbelievers therefore cut off their
name and cut off every fingertip
that's one okay that's one there are a
hundred and forty to go to surah 5 go to
surah I don't come here and pretend to
me that your book is any different than
any other sector is like I've studied
the Quran and I've studied the Bible let
me tell you one thing yeah and this is a
fact if you follow the Quran to the
letter
you are holy I thought how many before
he kills that's the point Orrico 5 equal
your Quran santista
yes it does not know make a proud of
yourself darling which is cited in it
let me clarify right within a terrifying
sight that really silly if you come to
me said to me there are verses in the
Quran say kill to perform and I don't
agree with them how to set you right you
probably not a Muslim you're an apostate
you haven't said that we've said to me
is I'm a devout Muslim yes it doesn't
say that in the Quran it says go into
the heart of disbelieve either they're
super fun
yeah can I have from just before you say
this for Irish I'm hands who's an
atheist here because what he's about to
do is he's about to say the people of
the book as in myself the Christians and
the Jews they're not real this man is
about to say there's there's been two
types of non-muslims yeah they are the
ones who are combatant and there's the
ones that are non-combative so for
example let me tell you every single one
of the genres in here or come baton and
you can rely on that
every single one of the genres in here
are combatant and you can rely on that
you can rely on trader my point is this
if I am coming or let's suppose Hitler
and Nazis are coming to Britain to
attack us we ask the British people have
to help our country and fight them off
that is not the same as us coming to
innocent Germans and say hey I'm gonna
kill you why you want to draw the
parallel not Caesar I love to do how you
tell me they have a Nazi sort of people
in concentration and then there were
people aligned themselves at a Nazi
Party that believes in everything an
article but they didn't do it themselves
are they just as fat yes you just
admitted that there are Muslim yes
support Islam the Islamic terrorists
support the atrocities that are dictated
and destructive in the Koran and
controlling your say and the people that
follow the ideology of Islam those who
follow the Nazi ideology are as bad as
the Nazis killing the Muslims following
Islam as an ideology yes you need to
accept Jesus that you quite clearly say
you can't salute to say that you stand
for if you do then the blood of every
innocent child from Manchester Arena
place on your hands the blood of
everybody on the bridges is on your
hands the blood of every single innocent
person in every single
Islamic terror attack is on your hands
but you know what sir
I'm glad you refused to shake my hand
because there's nothing worse and
there's someone who stands for something
but it's too weak to admit it so let me
tell you
you sir are my enemy yes you are yes you
are you know what
I said I do not come in peace
but I come with a sword I come to turn
mother against son against father
against son mother against son-in-law
let me tell you if you think because
we're Christians and I'm holding this
cross the you could come here you can
lie in our faces and then you can attack
our people then you let your people know
and as you can see as you can see when I
can clearly show them I said okay me
show me a single verse in the Quran that
says go out and kill innocent people
she gave a speech go be of crap and said
bye bye I'm going this is exactly the
problem cuz she knows very well she
knows very well
[Music]
okay okay
obviously you can't say it there because
that yeah that's that's not problem I
just want to say something the reason
why cuz you see they would clearly you
would see them
for example Jada and golden and their
team they go to Muslim areas which
Monday and they go to Germany and what
they do is they go to these areas and
they go to these ignorant Muslims who
can't even speak English properly okay
well how do you respect and they talk
yeah and they know they can't do a reply
but when somebody who knows this
scripture a bit comes and challenges
them what happens all of a sudden they
say oh we don't want to speak and then
she gave a speech everybody crap I need
to go now
this is exactly the problem because they
know intellectually they have no next to
stand on and they know clearly nowhere
in the Quran does it say go out there
and kill innocent men women and children
nowhere so that's why what they had to
do they had to cut us out because it
sabotages their whole objective that's
the reason why we came here today to
show you guys and I knew this was gonna
happen I knew they'd never let me speak
she's gonna speak all over me and she
knows for example one gonna say he's
gonna dismantle her or her whole claim
that's why look how they just push this
out
exactly but we're gonna each other try
to get the conversation back with them
hopefully data what happened
Jayda what happened to our conversation
oh come on my weapon David I'm too busy
come on man jada jada jada jada
where's where's she going what happened
to an international discussion why
should run anyway why should wanna go
home I know where you come from why is
she running off from them
jada jada jada jada why you know why do
you want to speak to me you go to Muslim
areas why why you gonna pick what
Muslims you don't know their religion I
do why are you afraid to talk to me I
voted come on
Boni can you show me a single verse in
the Quran that says Goku innocent people
you're cowards you guys are cowards you
are cowards
you caught me but not Muslims he won't
be good Muslim that I know the religion
I know my religion buddy run away jato
guys when it comes to ignorant Muslims
when it comes ignorant Muslims they
don't they don't mind they don't mind
but when it comes the ignorant Muslims
they act it but when it comes to people
who don't know what they're talking
about they don't want to know they don't
want to know but they're gonna know
[Applause]
so guys as you saw for yourself she came
with hey shake my hand knowing very well
as Muslims we dog she tried that didn't
work she came with you're doing takea
nah sorry I'm not sure didn't work she
came with your profit did violence this
that that sorry didn't work she came
with uh you're a Muslim if you're a
Muslim you should be coming if I'm
having enormous in did you kill sorry
low blow it didn't work she came with a
attitude aggressiveness shouting abuse
we are combatants it didn't work she
wanted me to get aggressive it didn't
work
I asked unchallenged show me a single
chapter in the entire Quran of the
history of Islam that says go kill
innocent men women children or anyone it
didn't work she couldn't show me one she
put all the verses all out of context
and all those verses are talking about
the best food when the enemy was
attacking them that's it and that they
pour golden goose Jade as a scapegoat
Jada used a security escape go but not
every day is gonna be like that day
we're gonna eventually come and
challenge you and expose you for how
what you really are one little advance
for me it could look at this face
because you're gonna be seeing a lot
more of it being Muslim on almost hit
pitches we're gonna come after you as
British people be a Muslim or non-muslim
are fed up of you hate prison and
innocent people dying and you will be
challenged